marry shag kill Joe Jonas exes edition
Andy Cohen put Joe Jonas in the hot seat
on Thursday nights watch what happens
live
they played fleet v and former Joe crow
dished on his famous exes Demi Lovato
Taylor Swift and most recently gigi
hadid you marry what you kill what you
shag one I married Emmy okay friend yes
this is a game right yes okay shag
Taylor killed them with Gigi okay there
you go
in April I asked Joe about a song he was
working on that might make someone
pretty angry it's asking you about a
tweet that you sent out and you said
it's always fun writing a song that's
gonna piss someone off yes explain what
this means songwriting is the artists
way of expressing their journal and
their their personal life people are
wondering what I'm what I'm thinking
about so it's nice to be able to put it
out there
once it's out will fans know who it's
about I mean as of right now you
definitely will know who it's about but
I think we'll have to sometimes have to
sugarcoat it so it's not so obvious and
II followed up and the 26 year old still
wouldn't reveal who it's about though
many suspect it's about gge after she
moved on so quickly with Zayn Malik who
is the person and have they heard the
song yet this song is not gonna be on
the album and who's the song about yes
plead the fifth